[Applause]  playing every other day this third game  the intensity of the playoffs  you can see it in these guys right now  murray trying to shake caruso here's a  three-pointer oh  it's good jamal murray  big shot for denver this one reggie  and this one was deep like come here  come here cruise  come here baby that was a big shot right  there sure the one that  the second one after that was  the near 30-footer murray caruso autumn  murray good pass  millsap got deep shot clock at five  murray looking for summon oh great find  and a two-headed energy at both ends  were fantastic  obviously you know what murray and jokic  did how about murray  oh just pours it in  jamal murray with an exclamation point  wow from way downtown  how about murray being aggressive all  night  takes his time finds his big man under  the basket to finish strong and after he  hits the long three  yeah he gonna let you know i'm feeling  myself